He may have dazzled audiences as
sparkly vampire Edward Cullen,
but behind the scenes, Robert
Pattinson had a dirty little
secret. Here's the gross habit that could
make fans see him in a whole new light.
The "Twilight" saga has everything you
could possibly want in a teen romance:
star-crossed lovers, a shockingly good soundtrack,
and a creepy telepathic baby. And instead of
sleeping in dusty old coffins, these vampires are
glimmering immortals, beautiful beyond compare.
However, Bella Swan still has a hard time choosing
between the mysterious Edward Cullen and the moody
werewolf Jacob Black. It seems like it would
be a pretty easy decision, especially because
Edward and the other vampires constantly remark
that Jacob and the werewolves carry a foul stench
with them wherever they go. But apparently,
the situation is reversed in real life.
During a 2012 interview with Extra,
Pattinson was asked to address a comment
he made about not washing his hair for
six weeks, and his answer would send every
scent-sensitive vampire running for the hills.
"I don't really see the
point in washing your hair."
"To be clean, maybe?"
"If you don't care if your hair's clean
or not then why would you wash it?"
Pattinson then compared his unwashed
hair to his untidy living space, saying,
"It's like, I don't clean my apartment 'cause I
don't care. I have my apartment for sleeping in
and I have my hair for just, you know, hanging out
on my head. I don't care if it's clean or not."
It can be hard to be objective about your
own cleanliness, but it's impossible to
know the truth when other sources have made
conflicting comments about Pattinson's hygiene.
The vampires in "Twilight" don't sweat, so
readers might like to imagine that Edward
smells like the pages of the books
in his bedroom and the crisp forest
air after climbing all those trees with Bella.
Unfortunately, one source says that Pattinson
smelled badly enough on set that it affected
his coworkers. An anonymous crew member who
worked closely with Pattinson during the
production of "New Moon" told E! News,
"He stinks. I mean, it's awful. He never showers,
and it drives people on the set
crazy. [...] He completely reeks."
Knowing that Pattinson himself said that he
doesn't have the best hygiene habits sucks
the romance out of all those scenes where
Edward and Bella get up in each other's
personal space. However, his co-star has
her own opinion on the subject. Kristen
Stewart told People before the first
film hit theaters in November 2008,
"He smells great. It's kind of an animalist thing
that goes on. It went along with
the movie, so it was perfect."
Pattinson has notoriously mocked the
"Twilight" franchise over the years,
so he clearly has a sense of humor. His
comments about hygiene could be true,
or just another self-deprecating joke.
Either way, Pattinson apparently made
some improvements to his self-care routine
after the "Twilight" franchise wrapped.
In 2013, it was announced that the actor
would become the face of Dior Homme fragrance,
which the company describes as having an alluring,
earthy scent. Surely a luxury brand like the House
of Dior wouldn't tap Pattinson for the job if
they didn't think his image could sell cologne,
though the actor admits that partnering
with the company may have, in fact,
improved his skincare regimen. Pattinson
explained to the Wall Street Journal in 2014,
"I was a brush-your-teeth-and-have-a-shower kind
of guy. I can't tell if it's because of my
association with Dior or because I'm older,
but I've started moisturizing. It's been
a quite profound change in my life."
"I like my smell."
An anonymous source from a movie set more than
a decade ago hardly counts as evidence. Still,
Pattinson’s apparent disregard for
hygiene may surprise some. As the
"Twilight" saga gears up to return as a TV series,
fans may wonder whether they prefer the new
Edward or the allegedly foul-smelling original.